[Music]
hey lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're gonna
have fun
tonight me guess another it conference
i'm gonna be back in a couple days toms
hey mom dad has a work emergency so can
you come pick me up i love it when you
call me mom let's throw a rager
what's happening
please don't touch me
[Music]
this is so tight it's some kind of
superhero lair your dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
step step step into the spotlight
i have a crazy idea
step into the spotlight
please don't kill me
now that's fast
we got him
[Music]
whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's attack before
they destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
oh dude that was too long
that was way too long
whoa whoa don't you i'm the i.t guy i
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am i supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right
yes
playtime's over kids
prepare for war
[Music]
things are warm yeah so hot you got the
winter suit
[Music]
[Music]
you